bonjour aboubaker barma merci de
répondre à nos questions on parle
beaucoup du contexte d'insécurité pour
ce scrutin
quel est le climat sécuritaire
aujourd'hui calme précaire règne à metz
et ce à des débordements sont ils à
craindre localement peu calorique bord
pour le moment les bureaux de vote
ouverts globalement vers 8 heures ça
fait déjà une raul
pour le moment il n'y a pas de grande
affluence dans les bureaux de vote
parce qu'ils seront ouverts jusqu'à 18
heures messe et calmes c'est pénible
il n'y a pas eu de débordement vous
savez comme pour le premier tour le vote
s'est déroulé tranquillement l'elysée la
grande attraction du vote donc le ch'ti
peter se déroule normalement pour le
moment pas de magie ont été signalés à
12 des voix ce climat sécuritaire tendu
est ce qu'il peut peser sur le taux de
participation 22 millions d'habitants
mais un peu plus de 7 millions
d'électeurs en raison d'une population
nigérienne très jeune
c'est vrai les menaces sécuritaires sont
ambiante mais pas tellement les
autorités ont pris les mesures
nécessaires
et puis vous savez comme le premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle et
législatives qui se sont passés le 27
décembre dernier qui a pâti de ces
dommages
et ces derniers temps on assista à un
calme relatif
il n'y avait pas eu de terre majeur les
zones où il ya les menaces et que tu es
de la région de diffa à l'est ou bien à
la frontière avec le mali et le bcla
sont des zones a relativement peu public
parce que l peu désertique donc la plus
pauvre de la population le plus gros des
électeurs c'est toute la bande sud du
pays ce qui fait que malgré les menaces
malgré le climat
le taux de participation n'est pas trop
trop menace vous a vu au premier tour il
ya deux mois il y avait jusqu'à presque
à 70% de participation alors qu'ils
avaient guidé attaque même la vie et ces
derniers jours on a parlé d' attaques
qu'ils soient civils ou autres les
militaires comme ce qui me fait dire que
il ne pèsera pas forcément sur le taux
des taxes passion le niger est le
dernier pays au monde sur l'indicé
loppement humains près de 42% de la
population vit dans l'extrême pauvreté
quels sont les enjeux du coût de cette
élection le partage des richesses parce
qu'on rappelle le niger est le quatrième
producteur mondial d'uranium
oui le partage des richesses pas
forcément mal puisque déjà c'est un pays
bord que les richesses a pas forcément l
uranium de passe plus grand chose dans
vous savez avec depuis les événements de
fukushima
la peste et il ya déjà la baisse à 2
comme on appelle ça la baisse du coût
des prix de l'uranium
il ya aussi le visage est un pays
producteur de pétrole mais pas forcément
pour le moment devait changer pour les
nigérians c'est la stabilité parce que
c'est la première fois qu'un président
de la république d'ici au niger depuis
l'indépendance en 1960 va finir un
mandat de dix années et a dit il va
finir de mada est mordu de mangas de 55
ans et il va passer le témoin à elle
note que pour la première fois les
électeurs vont voter petit programme
ceux ci qui a été accompli souhaite
vouloir ou le singe et donc c'est
vraiment la stabilité politique pour que
les institutions commence à fonctionner
et à véritablement se mettre à
travailler pour le développement mais
les difficultés roth
la principale c'est la stabilité l'enjeu
principal du scrutin
c'est vraiment la stabilité c'est
vraiment la première transition
démocratique lacrymal classe politique
pour les pays en mots justement sur les
deux candidats vous parler de stabilité
mohamed bazoum donné favori face à lui à
mahamane ousmane donc l'alternance dans
la continuité d'un côté et puis le vieux
monde de l'autre comment la presse
nigérienne vous qui êtes journaliste
qualifie ces deux candidats du comment
la population les juge tout simplement
qu'elle se soit au niveau des analystes
qui s'assoit au niveau 2
de la presse vous savez même si les deux
cas le damné partent pas avec les mêmes
chances base on va mettre comme candidat
d'un coup du parti au pouvoir part
favori figure relativement aux vies son
score au premier tour mais pour nous ici
au niger
ces deux candidats qu'ils s'assoient
ousmane et bazou sont de la même
génération si c'est qu'on appelle ici la
génération post démocratique c'est à
dire ils ont fait leur apparition sur la
scène politique à partir des années 90
notamment au lendemain de la conférence
nationale qui a suivi le discours de la
baule de la phrase qui a suivi la
conférence nationale lorsque l'univers à
instaurer la démocratie et le
multipartisme en 1990 2 c les deux tel
ou tel a enquêté et des acteurs majeurs
tout comme mamadou bazou a été ministre
depuis 90 qui était leader syndical
maman odile agir ou répondre à la
conférence nationale mahamane ousmane a
été le premier président qui a été élu
justement pour la petite histoire
lorsque mahamane ousmane le camp de l
opposition aujourd'hui a été lui le
premier président démocratiquement élu
du niger en 93 c'était avec le soutien
du pnds de mahamadou issoufou et dans
son gouvernement
il y avait besoin doit mettre donc c'est
des gens qui se connaissent ils sont de
la même génération du pic 98 30 ans soit
qu'ils sont alliés soit qu'ils son
opposant c'est ce qu'on appelle ici les
vieux loups de la politique nigérienne
de l'ère post démocratique donc même si
c'est un changement de programme c'est
un changement de gouvernance mais les
deux ce qui sont de la même mouture de
la même génération démocratique au niger
merci à boubacar ba hmad avoir répondu à
une question je rappelle que vous êtes
le rédacteur en chef du
médiasactu niger 6